welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 22 and
we're gonna learn how you can get
customers for your business like a
billionaire
enjoy
[Music]
henry ford as you may know failed twice
before he started the
ford motor company in 1903 i mean the
the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you
keep learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers
what you can bring especially to the
party and to do that
you need you need a
genuine a genuine desire
day in day out to
delight the customer i've never
i've never seen a business and i've seen
a lot of businesses but i've never seen
one that
delights the customer that that doesn't
succeed
i mean what you want is that customer
the next day when they think do i want
to rent a car
or do i want to buy some furniture what
goes through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great experience um
i don't know what i paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech i will
say i i have no idea but what i or the
shirt i'm wearing others
but i do know i will remember
how i was treated when i bought it i
mean
you long forget about the price
but you never forget whether you had a
good experience
or a poor experience uh with
the purchase experience i think one of
the things i want to share with the
values
the six values among the two values very
unique in alibaba which i think the
whole world should
think about we put custom number one
in play number two shareholder number
three most
companies in wall street they put the
shareholder number one
i said each customer
is the most important if you serve them
well they pay you the money
and the second important is colleagues
why the college get together because
they want to serve the customers
if they do not cost serve the customers
why we get it together
right so if the customer happy in price
happy
the shareholders will be happy one of
the unusual things that we do
in the kindle device business is we sell
our hardware near break even
and so we make money when people use the
device
not when they buy the device and that is
very aligning
with customers if i buy a device and i
put in my desk drawer and never use it
then amazon doesn't deserve to make any
money
likewise it causes us to have the right
kinds of
behaviors so for example if we're not
making money when people buy the device
then we don't need people to be on the
upgrade
treadmill they can we have people who
are still using
five-year-old kindle ones and we're
perfectly happy about that
aws is very similar because it's a
pay-as-you-go
service we are not incented to get
people to
overbuy hardware to operate at low
utilization rates
our point of view on this is if we can
arrange
things in such a way that our interests
are aligned with our customers
then in the long term that will work out
really well
for customers and it'll work out really
well for
amazon we haven't had any existential
crisises
knock on wood i find i don't want to
jinx anything um
but we've had a lot of uh kind of
dramatic events i remember
early on we only had 125
employees when barnes noble who the big
united states bookseller opened their
online website to compete against us
barnesandnoble.com we'd had about a
two-year
window we opened in 95 they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be
destroyed by this much larger company we
had 125 employees
and 60 million dollars a year in annual
sales
60 million with an m and that
and barnes noble at the time had 30 000
employees and about 3 billion dollars in
sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were
um very negative about amazon and the
one that's most minimal or memorable was
just amazon.toast and
and so i called an all-hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people
and we got in a room and because it was
so um scary
for all of us this idea that now we
finally had a big competitor
that literally everybody's parents were
calling
and saying you know are you okay it's
usually the moms
um calling and asking their children are
you gonna be okay
so and i said look you know it it's okay
to be afraid
um but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never going
to send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them in
in in in instead of obsessing over this
big competitor that we just got
that we'll be fine and i really do
believe that i think that if you stay
focused then the more
uh drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is
the the what your response to it should
be to
double down on the customer satisfying
them not just satisfying them delighting
them
invention is not disruptive only
customer adoption
is disruptive at amazon we've invented a
lot of
things that customers did not care about
at all and believe me they were not
disruptive to anyone so it's only when
customers like the new way
that anything becomes disruptive and so
really it's just
saying that you want to you know if
somebody comes to you with a business
plan that they claim is disruptive
you should ask them to explain it to you
in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
why are they going to like it why is it
better
than the traditional way do you shop on
amazon yeah
and if you have something the service
you don't like yeah
so do you just pick up the phone call
your team of 700 000 people
and tell them i don't like this change
this or you know what i do
so um i don't do this it doesn't happen
that often but if i get a
delivery that i don't like maybe like
with package or something
we have regular meetings of the senior
executive team
and i bring the box to the meeting and
when i walk in i haven't done this in a
while it's been a while but when i
bring in a box everybody in the room is
like oh no he's bringing in a box
because it's always some problem but
really the way i get feedback
is to is primarily from my email address
is very well known and i keep it well
known and i get
hundreds and hundreds of emails every
day from customers
and they always have something
interesting to say when something goes
wrong
because we have hundreds of millions of
customers around the world and no matter
how good we are
we can still be better you can always be
better
customers have a divine discontent and
they teach you if you listen to
customers
so we watch for that and we see patterns
and we can find places where it's not
working
something's going wrong and that's
really how i get the feedback
is from customer input and often you
know
in all caps angry you ruined my child's
birthday because the gift didn't show up
on time
and we take that and what you really
want to do
is you take that it's an anecdote it's a
single example
but you need to find the root cause what
went wrong
deep inside the system how did this
happen because then you can fix it for
everyone
so that particular problem will never
happen again you don't just fix the
symptom you have to fix the root cause
and that's been the secret to our
operational success for 20 years
we got this company just about ready to
launch
and uh we're looking at it looking at
this little tiny
fulfillment center we were here by then
in this building
we had a basement fulfillment center to
call it a fulfillment center was very
grand there's a lot of puffery
it was 400 square feet which is about
the size of a one car garage
and we launched this business and
we're looking at it and we didn't know
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't
and in fact one of the uh software
engineers looked at this little space
and he said i can't figure out whether
this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
um and indeed we didn't know we had no
idea whether anybody would want to buy
things in this way the business plan
called for uh generating sales very
slowly as customers changed their
attitudes the original business plan
which i thought was very optimistic at
the time
called for amazon.com to generate 70
million dollars in sales in the year
2001.
we actually generated an excess of 3
billion dollars in sales
in the year 2001 and we knew by the way
that we were really on to something in
those first 30 days
in the first 30 days we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries
with not a dollar of advertising just
all word of mouth the first year we
didn't spend anything on advertising
all of it was word of mouth and that
really forged the company as a that we
were going to focus on customer
experience because we saw the power of
word of mouth so
so very very clearly in those early days
there's something great about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being
it's wonderful so people actually tell
you what they really think
uh usually in all caps
and uh so we get lots of uh
info and feedback from our customers and
we try to try to use it well
i believe that the primary success
factor for amazon.com
has been an obsession over the customer
and a focus on customer service
this is clearly important in any
business but especially
important online and the reason for this
is that
word of mouth is incredibly powerful
online if you make a customer unhappy on
the internet they won't tell
five friends they will tell five
thousand friends on usnet news groups
and listservs and so on
likewise of course if you can make a
customer happy by meeting or exceeding
their expectations
they can also tell five thousand people
and
therefore you know be evangelists for
you they can use the internet as a
megaphone
so it's very important to do the things
that you actually are going to claim to
do
and what this means basically is the
balance of power
has shifted away from the merchant and
toward the consumer
which is a great thing i think for
everybody involved it's even great for
the merchant as long as the merchant
realizes it
one of the statistics that we track most
carefully at amazon.com
because we believe that this is so
important is our
the fraction of orders we receive we
receive every day
that are from repeat customers and that
number has consistently gone
up and it's now over 58 of our orders
that we receive every day
even in the context of a very rapid new
customer growth
the 99 95 5 rule there are no spare
you know 95 of everything we do is right
every day in business but look for the
five percent you do wrong and that's
what makes you better than everybody
else
there are no spare customers okay it's a
competitive world and every one of our
businesses
take no out of your damn vocabulary you
you're on a business trip
and it's 1102 you hang up the phone and
and uh on a call and you call down to
order some breakfast
and they say i'm sorry sir we don't
serve breakfast anymore that's okay no
problem i don't need a waffle or
or an eggs benedict just throw a couple
eggs and a skillet and send them up
scrambled however it's easy for you to
do
i'm sorry sir we don't serve breakfast
why are you telling me no
i didn't ask you for anything special
you're gonna throw a burger in the pan
just throw me a couple of eggs and
take care of me be you're in the
hospitality business
okay and you're telling me no and
everybody's in the hospitality business
no matter what they do
you take care of your customer okay you
take care of your customers
it's no different than we walk in and
your people meet us polite you put a
welcome up on the screen
you come in here everybody couldn't be
can i get you some water tell me can
can i do this for you you're in the
service business so why do you want to
be an ass
and and say no to somebody when it's
just as easy to say yes
or do you just give an alternative the
company's being run by somebody who's
not
i get a lot of questions from other
people who run companies about
organizations
um i think that if you the important
thing that you do is about
measurability and repeatability then
hierarchical organizations are
appropriate
but that's not what is happening in our
industry the rate of innovation is not
remaining constant it's not like we're
plateauing
in just about every dimension innovation
is increasing and the most effective
organizations
are those that can self-organize and
that are relatively
that are extremely flat and that the
question when you're trying to
think about how your how your company is
organized or how you want it to grow
is how you can deliver help people
deliver smart and creative people create
the most value and delivered as
efficiently as possible to your
customers one of the most important
lessons we've learned is that
you have to be in partnership with your
customers whether it's the fact that we
have 200 000 servers around the world
running our games
uh whether it's the mods and content
that you're creating that that
partnership
that collaboration uh that starts when
you're designing the game and thinking
about how this
the main character of your story doesn't
have a copy of your script and yet
somehow
you're supposed to be creating this
narrative experience and this
interactive entertainment with them all
the way through every line of business
function which is
most support questions end up getting
answered by people on your forums
it's that partnerships that's important
this is sort of like the steve jobs
question do you think you should focus
on making something that you believe
people want or something that you want i
definitely
think it should i would focus it should
be on something that that
uh that people want you um but uh but i
think the the nuance on this is
you shouldn't um there's always a
question whether
you're making the judgment or you're
taking some survey of people
to make the judgment and uh and so i'm
very much in the steve jobs camp
of uh you want to have like this esp
link
to the population at large and
understand what they want
better than they understand themselves
and i i i take the view that
people don't generally know what they
want and so if you ask them surveys if
you do market studies
you will not actually get get the right
answer and so
so there is something about sort of this
inspired um
you know
inspired intuition about what uh what
the world as a whole wants
you have to execute everybody's got
ideas you know that's that's the easy
part
but customer what sale
customer customer happy yes or no
sale customer customer happy yes or no
right sale because everything just feeds
that
right everything else is noise and if
you
and part of that though so there is a
part b to that right
because one tenant of good business is
always listening to your customers
right you always want to listen but you
don't always want to do what they tell
you
right because the customer's job is to
just
is to to make their company successful
right
and when they tell you what they need
and what they tell you what they want
they're typically thinking about the
right here and now they're not thinking
about your potential competitors
they're not thinking about the future of
your organization so you have to also
innovate you have to differentiate
so you have to have be out here
innovating differentiating
understanding you know how you fit
within your industry and how you can get
ahead
but then you have to turn that into
sales customers
customer happiness and so if you can
execute on those things things typically
work out well
it's not well my office is pretty my
office always looks like crap
right i mean our offices now we we have
these varidesks everywhere
i'm not you know you don't have to look
the part i mean i certainly never have
right um you don't have to sound the
part you just have to find a way to put
your customers in a position to succeed
and good things happen
one time you know as you know i went to
indiana and
in dallas in the mid 90s you know when
when we had a good basketball team
we we literally would when we wanted to
listen to our big games like indiana
purdue go hoosiers
um we would call somebody in bloomington
who would put a radio next to a speaker
phone
and dial us and we'd sit on the other
side listening over a speakerphone
drinking our beer and whipping it up or
doing whatever
and the internet was just starting to
happen and now i'm a tech geek and i'm
like into all of it
and we're like there's got to be a
better way to do this and so
one of my buddies from indiana todd
wagner was like look
we've been thinking about this and i'm
like no i'll figure it out i'm a
networking
guy now and so we looked for ways to
um stream indiana basketball we called
it net casting back then
over the brand new internet and so i
went out and bought a packard bell
90 megahertz computer and an isdn line
and downloaded all the software and i
said you know what i'm going to figure
it out
and lo and behold by oh golly
early 1995 we had figured out a way
to we would we took
these eight-hour vcrs and connected it
to a local radio station record them
we'd bring them back go through this
process called encoding and put it up on
this
website we call it audionet and then i'd
go to any online forum
aol prodigy compuserve uunet whatever it
was or you use use
usenet and i like if you're interested
in dallas sports at all because we
hadn't gotten to indiana yet if you're
interested
in dallas sports go to this website
audionet
and back then you had a dial-up modem
you had to download this software called
tcpip
and you had to have software from your
internet provider
which meant that so few people knew how
to use it we had no idea if it would
work or not
but all of a sudden audionet went from
10 people a day to 100 people
to a thousand people a day and as we
added radio stations they're getting
calls from all over the world from
people
who are listening to their shows on
demand not even lined
and then we worked with a company that
put together live software company
called zing
and we made it live and then everything
changed and that's really when streaming
was born and
we just grew that and then in 1998 we
got into video changed the name to
broadcast.com
went public and it was the biggest ipo
in the history of the stock market at
the time
and then we sold it to yahoo people
often ask me
what it takes to start a business what
is the key ingredient how do i how do i
start the business and
how do we grow to about 20 million
dollar 20 million dollars in sales so
quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're gonna invent the
the better mouse trap they're gonna come
up with new software new hardware
and more often than not it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
they thought through their idea
but when we talk about new companies and
and growth and success
there really is only one common
ingredient
across any type of business whether it's
oil or computers or software anything
and that key ingredient
is customers without customers
when you're starting a business running
a business
expanding a business you don't have a
business
there is no business customers are the
key ingredient to get those profits
you gotta have the customers you gotta
have happy customers
that's the bottom line you know micro
solutions we've been we've been going
and growing
and it's impossible not to have growing
pains it's impossible not to make
mistakes
we screw up all the time and you know it
doesn't bother me as president
if i ever if i have an employee who just
didn't do something right
just made a mistake it's good because if
you're not making mistakes you're not
trying hard enough
you know these things i'm saying they're
not unique they're not things that i
just thought up in some
some miracle growth you know things when
i talk to people in our company when i
talk to people about our company
i never have a unique thought i can't
remember i don't know that i ever did i
can't remember if i ever will or don't
expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right
these these sayings that you hear me say
are things that i've read elsewhere and
just regurgitate back but how many
people do them
you know we all know the golden rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and that's nice you know but do you do
it
but even more importantly than the
golden rule what about the lover's rule
do on to others as you would love to
have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress the micro
solution that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay
you're going to offer them coffee you're
going to offer them a doughnut
and that's really what you expect you
know if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice if you go back fine if you
don't go back
fine that's the way customers look at
businesses
if i go back fine if i don't go back
fine you know they say that 80
of the people who have a problem tell at
least 10 people
only 10 of the people who had a good
experience tell anybody and it's the
same way when you go to visit an
acquaintance
when people come to try to do business
with micro solutions i hope
i pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason to want to
come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning wrap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you
if you want to make a quick buck you can
do it a lot of different ways
you can cheat somebody you can
misrepresent something you can
go manipulate the political system to
get an advantage but if you want to
if you want to be successful over a long
period of time i believe
you need to be to focus first of all on
creating value for others
and that said oh that's i've had people
well that's naive
that's utopian no it isn't because why
will the customers want to pay you
anything
over a long period unless you're
creating value for them
why would your your employees want to
work for you
or if they did they didn't have any
alternative why do they want to give
their best efforts
why do they want to get excited why
would they wake up at night with ideas
if you're in a community a plant in a
community unless you're creating value
for that community
why would the community want you there
if you're polluting
and hurting people and not contributing
anything to the community
so long-term success starts with being
dedicated to creating value for others
it's it's not altruism it's
my whole philosophy is is to have a
system of mutual benefit
where both parties gain a society based
on
win-win how would you characterize your
company's success today
well we we take risks we're innovative
we listen to the customer we are
obsessed
with what do you want what is working
what isn't working i
love to ask people questions you know i
am my own consumer
so i categorize us this is how i feel
about the fashion industry
i feel like the old adage beauty is pain
yeah i call that bs
before spanx because it doesn't have to
be pain
and i realized by breaking into the
industry that the reason why was because
the people making almost everything we
were wearing
weren't having to spend all day in it so
there wasn't that extra bit of love or
that extra bit of attention
i built the first version of facebook
because it's something that
my friends and i wanted to use at
harvard a directory and a way to connect
with
the other people around us and i i
didn't think at all that it was going to
be a company i remember very
specifically
the night that that we launched um the
first version i went out to
to get pizza with um a couple of my
friends who
um who now work here and you know and
i remember really clearly we were
talking about how one day
we thought that someone was going to
build a community like this for the
world
uh and that that would be some company
but it like
it clearly wasn't going to be us i mean
it just it wasn't even it didn't even
occur
yeah no i mean it wasn't even an option
that we considered that it might be us i
mean we just weren't focused on building
a company back then we were just
building something that that that we
thought would be
useful at our school with facebook there
was just such you know people loved it
right
and had such an intensity of using it i
think within a couple of weeks
two-thirds of students at harvard were
using it and all these other students at
mit and other local universities
were writing in asking us if we could
open up uh facebook
at their school so we kind of just
followed that right and you know again
we didn't
i didn't set out and you know my
roommates didn't set out to to build
a service that we're going to turn into
a company but we just kind of followed
what people wanted and that
led us to expand it to all these other
schools and um
and eventually beyond schools and to you
know at some point
uh once we'd hired a bunch of people we
decided to turn it into a company and
and um and go for this mission of
connecting the world but that's not
where we started i always think that you
should start with
the problem that you're trying to solve
in the world and not start with um
deciding that you want to build a
company right the best companies that
that get built
are things that are trying to drive some
kind of social change even if it's
just local in one place uh you know more
than starting out because you want to
make a bunch of money or
have a lot of people working for you or
or build some company in some way so
you know i always think that this is
kind of a perverse thing about silicon
valley in a way that's really which is
that
you know people decide often that they
want to start a company before they even
decide what they want to do
and that just feels really backwards to
me and
you know for anyone who's had the
experience of actually building a
company you know that you go through
some really hard things along the way
and i think part of what
gets you through that is believing in
what you're doing
and knowing that what you're doing is is
really
delivering a lot of value for people um
and that's i think how the best
companies end up getting made we've
probably spent less money in marketing
than any
company our size in the world we have a
tiny marketing department
and everyone says why oracle's you know
all about sales and marketing
we are the largest employer of mit and
caltech engineers in the world
we are the largest employer of stanford
and
harvard and cmu mathematicians in the
world
we are overwhelmingly dominated by
engineering
at oracle the idea that we are a sales
and marketing company which people
will sometimes will write about quite
often is
ludicrous on the face of it because
all of our customers who buy oracle
already have it
and if you already have oracle there's
nothing a salesman can tell you about
how great it is to make you buy more
ge already uses it the defense
department always you already use it
all of our customers 98 of our sales or
more
are to existing oracle customers if we
don't have the right product
people don't buy more we will
before the acquisition we spend three
billion dollars a year in software
engineering
the company is all about engineering
it's the only thing that works how would
you describe
each phase of the evolution of oracle
and how would you
uh sort of describe running each of
those phases
you got to do this quick i gotta
well i mean and clearly being a part of
a company with four people and being a
part of a company and by the way this
we're 85 000 now post
post merger with sun you know uh on 100
uh we think about
sun's got about 20 000 employees and you
know uh 25 000 employees we're about 105
000.
so uh hundred five hundred ten thousand
we're not sure exactly
about that uh i mean clearly my job is
constantly changed uh
what has not changed is i ran
engineering at oracle on the first day
i run engineering today the one part of
the company i have always paid attention
to
and is always reported directly to me is
engineering not
sales not marketing not support and not
consulting not
services at various points in time lots
of other people have run
run those operations the back office
accounting
order management all of these things the
only thing that i've done
consistently during those 32 years is
run engineering because i believe
basically that once you reach yeah you
will you know you win
as as as we say at oracle it's amazing
our good products seem to do very well
and our bad products not so well
so the thing i focused on and i think we
get the most most leverage
is developing the right products
recruiting the right engineers and
having the right organization
when i wrote the 10x rule i was trying
to solve a problem the problem that i've
had in my life okay
was not my marriage it's not okay i'm
not a bad parent
i wasn't helping enough people see i've
always loved helping people
always i am most happy when i'm helping
someone else nothing to do with money
if i can help somebody not give them
something
but if i can actually help somebody to
feel better about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do in a sales call
to know how to follow up their
girlfriend or their boyfriend or to
solve some problem in their life or how
to get some money
if i can help somebody know how to do
that i know i contributed to their life
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling
you should be helping more people 10x
gave me my life back
if you're not 10xing i promise you will
experience depression
you will feel empty okay i wanted my
life back
are you committed no no no are you
committed
[Music]
will you let me help you
welcome to your 10x growth conference
one of the huge things you helped my
brother and i with
was um getting giving the customer
options okay so we went from just like
hey here's your price there's only one
thing you can do
to now giving like warranty options one
year five-year 10-year 20-year
we also give a time and material option
and the problem
i've been having with that is you give
the time material option the customer
always goes
well how much is it going to be they
still want a price when yeah you want
i don't want a time and material i want
to know a number so i don't pay with
time and materials i pay with
dollars exactly so so we would then give
a range and now the customer's like well
what's the range all about so yeah it
does grab all that and just yeah you
know
that ranges ranges suggest
that you're not sure you know
you the doctor says look you only have a
little bit to live
how long i got doc i don't know
somewhere between three days and
six weeks hey man dude
yeah so no time and material at all
i mean i i would just give numbers
okay so i don't know what it is for me
for me to give a number on something i'm
not sure
i i i'm probably gonna have to like hey
look man i'm thinking 200 grand i'm
thinking a project your size is going to
be 200 grand
now let me just say this if i added bing
bing bing and bing
we could be at 340 okay but let me
suggest that the better solution would
be
we go ahead and do this thing for 4 40
while i'm here and we get bang bang bang
and bing done
i don't know what that is right so i'm
just using the bing bang
thank you man right but but but but and
while i'm writing a proposal with
choices always use alternatives
when you're doing this in the pricing
and in the close
and in the follow-up and in the push
you should always offer three choices
and two you should always offer it
in writing so you're having a
conversation right now
between here and here you cannot close a
conversation
conversations don't close this does
the conversation i was having with him i
understand from this distance i cannot
close him
all i'm doing is talking with him we're
just talking
okay you will never transact on
conversation
listen to what i'm telling you right now
you cannot transact
on a conversation you have to have
i i would need to have ryan move from
the wall over there
and have him sign up something on
cardone capital to close that deal
same thing for a listing same thing for
a contract same thing for a house deal
same thing for a masseuse same thing for
the healthcare same thing for a
chiropractor
right i need to move them to an offer
and this is why i'm doing this there's
some things that you
never ever want to tell a customer and i
want to go over these with you okay
never tell them i don't know never say i
can't do that
never ever say it's a company policy
would you mind holding
is a pet peeve of mine beyond belief
because you don't care
if i mind or not you put me on hold
anyway and oh
this is the one that kills me that's
impossible let's take one at a time okay
first of all when you tell somebody i
don't know a customer asks you a
question you say
i don't know what you just told them was
you're wasting your time with me i'm an
idiot i am a reservoir of no data
what you'd want to tell them is if you
don't know say
that's a great question let me find out
for you see i just changed that
don't tell them you're an idiot or just
once you post something on your head i'm
an
idiot i know nothing okay number two i
can't do that
when you tell somebody you can't do that
let's say they ask for a price or
can you ship it at this time or whatever
and you're like i can't do that it's
negative you sound like you're not
willing to help people
look say yeah i'd be happy to work that
out for you i was in a hotel once and i
said
hey can you upgrade me to a suite the
ladies like i can't do that we're full
i'm like why don't you check see the way
she should have done it was this
mr cardone i'd be happy to do that for
you let me see what i have available
and then come back and say hey i don't
have any availability see the difference
people are so quick to say what they
can't do and what they don't know
number three it's a company policy dude
i don't care about your company policy
okay
break it i was at the four seasons hotel
this morning
and i went to sit in this little place
and they said hey it's a company policy
or the four seasons policy the kids
can't sit here i'm like dude i don't
care about that company policy
make an exclusion to it i don't care
what the four seasons decided a week ago
a month ago
six months ago somebody fell out of the
chair or whatever dude i want to sit
here this is what we're going to do i
don't care about your company policies
there's got to be a better way to say
that what you want to say is what
sir you know what this is a really
unsafe place i just want to make you
aware of it we had this thing happen
here i got a much better location for
you over here
see the difference in the delivery this
is a grant ramp man i'm just keeping it
real with you
the way you're responding to people is
costing you time it's costing you money
it's costing your customers
hey would you mind holding your
receptionist would you mind holding your
damn right-eyed mind don't put me on
hold damn it and i'm already on hold
don't do that
just say this hold please don't ask a
question
give them a command tell them what you
need to do hold one second i'll be right
back with you
i need one second and the last one is
that's impossible look we're not going
to the moon
i'm not asking you to go to another
universe i'm not asking you to go to
another planet and bring back minerals i
asked you to get me some paperwork or
make me a copy or get me a brochure
and you're going to answer like that's
impossible come on man get your game on
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
i think you need to be your customer's
chief goal officer i think if you want
to win in business you have to
understand your customers you become
their chief goal officer if you want to
accomplish your goals
the best way to get there is help your
customers accomplish their goals if
you're helping them
you're solving problems guess what
you're going to make money they're going
to pay you to do it
now you have to combine what they want
right you're the chief goal officer
this is what they want and combine it
with what you love doing can you help
them solve that problem are you the
person to solve it or do you want to
refer somebody else
off to them to solve that problem when
you can mix those things together the
thing you
absolutely love doing with what the
customer so desperately wants
that's when you start to win so look at
this youtube channel as an example
the content is a mix of what you guys
like and what i like
it has to be that mix from the beginning
the content that i was putting up
became requests from people who were
emailing me who then started leaving
comments to say hey can you do it on
this or i have this kind of question
hey can you do this kind of video and if
i like it i have something to say
great a lot of the stuff i may not have
anything to say so
i don't do it but whenever there's that
mix we make the video
even simon how did i learn about simon
from you guys
from people who are leaving comments and
say hey evan you should do a video on
simon sonic
when you first left those comments i had
no idea who he was
i was pretty ignorant i didn't know a
lot of people i still don't know a lot
of people
i had no idea who he was we did a little
bit of research on him said wow this is
this is pretty cool i like this guy yeah
we could totally do a top 10 on him
right you wanted it i liked it the match
is there
let's make the video and now that video
i didn't expect it to do so well it's
one of my top
five videos it's got i think five
million views or something
when i recorded it i was sick you know i
was sick i had my baseball hat on
backwards i'm sitting down in the chair
things a little graphic on the screen
that says evan is sick this week
and regardless videos goes up i never
thought it would be a top five video
on my channel if i did maybe i would
have
waited so i wasn't sick or maybe would
have done it anyway i probably still
would have just done it anyway
just because but i never thought it
would take off like it did
and so it's that combination what i love
with what you guys love
i'm trying to be your chief goal officer
and then match that in a way that i can
contribute content to you
look at what i've done with my youtube
channels now i split them up
we've got seven different channels part
of that's based off of how hopefully
youtube will rank my channel differently
and part of it's based off of your
feedback st evan i like some of these
videos but i don't like some of the
other ones
i wish you had a channel just for the
espresso series and just for the top 10
series
and so at the end of the day still has
to work this is an experiment
where i don't know seven eight nine ten
weeks in by the time this video comes up
and we'll see if it ends up working out
or not but the way the way to test it is
to test it
like you won't know until you go off and
do it and so by paying attention to the
feedback
and the comments i make decisions
and it has to be something that then i
like to right and so you have to get
close to your customers
stop letting people get in between you
and your customers
you need to have a relationship with
your customers people have to feel like
you know them and you have to feel like
you know them too to actually know
what's going
inside their head so you can provide
products or services that can help them
so i'm going to give you a three-step
process that i think will really help
step number one is be their chief goal
officer
it is your job to think about what is my
customer's number one
goal and how can i help them accomplish
that maybe if that even means totally
changing my business model around
making your business not for you or not
just for you
but that mix right so just start asking
yourself that question think about a
customer think about somebody who's
bought from you recently
and ask yourself that question how can
it be their chief gold officer
what do they want out of life what do
they want in their business how can i
help them solve that
problem step number two is pay attention
to feedback there's so much feedback
coming in now
online you get so many opportunities for
me i want every comment on youtube
responded to and i have two full-time
people now who are responding
to my comments across my social media
platforms and they save the content that
i need to see they save the comments
that
are directed directly at me that i need
to see that i need to respond to
and most of them they respond to
themselves so for example
hey evan you should do a top 10 on xyz
perfect i don't need to see that yet it
goes to my team they look at the
research
they find out there's enough content on
that person and if there is they'll
bring it to me and we'll make a decision
and move forward from there
most people when they start building up
a youtube channel they got their bad
response responding everybody's comments
but then at some point it becomes
unsustainable if i was sitting in the
comments responding to every comment
i would run out of time like there just
isn't enough time even if that was my
full-time job there's not enough time
i have two full-time people who are
doing comments across my
my platform which means i'm creating
zero content if i'm just now responding
to comments
and so most youtubers at some point just
give up on it they just give up they say
okay you know what i'm gonna respond the
comments
in the first 30 minutes of my video
going up or i'm going to spend
half an hour a day responding to
comments and that's it or i'm only going
to respond to the comments
with people who have 100 000 subscribers
or more the important people
right that's all i'm going to respond to
people set their own rules i think i
think it's all flawed
you you scale your business to pay
attention to feedback
any company as you're growing sooner or
later the phones are going to be ringing
off the hook
right it doesn't mean that you have to
answer them but somebody does
you hire somebody you build your team
you need to pay attention to the
feedback whether that's comments on
social media
whether that's reviews online whether
that's emails coming into your
your accounts you have to pay attention
to the feedback if you're going to be
somebody's chief goal officer
you got to see it now are you doing the
work are you helping them are you
getting results right is
is your project working even this kind
of video
we're tackling a more hardcore business
topic than the usual mindset motivation
stuff
maybe you guys love it maybe you hate it
maybe you're like hey evan
never do this kind of video again i want
mindset every morning
not this hardcore business stuff dump it
i don't know we'll see what you guys say
i'll see what's happening in the
comments and we'll make a decision
whether we do more of the more business
technical stuff
i like it it's fun for me but it has to
be something you guys want and need as
well
so step number one is be their chief
goal officer step number two is pay
attention to feedback and step number
three is go say hi
just go say hi don't sit up on some
ivory tower
and lose the connection to your
customers you have to go say hi i love
meeting entrepreneurs i just came back
from this 90-day 23 city tour
and almost every day i'm meeting
different entrepreneurs
like i like being in the trenches i'm
still
not going off and making content and
writing books and doing all this other
stuff
but you can't actually help people
unless you're with them
and you might have been with them a year
ago or five years ago or whenever you
started your company you were one of
them but then you've evolved and become
some other animal
you need to go back and be that person
again you need to be in there
with them go say hi shake their hands
the feedback that you get
is is more big data if five of you guys
say i love this video and and 500 say
this video sucks great we won't do this
kind of content
likely again that's more bigger data
the same high the shaking people's hands
is qualitative
i guarantee you if you spent time every
month or every week
with your customers saying hi face to
face going to see them in business
take them out for coffee ask them about
what their problems are
you will gain so much insight that will
generate so many new ideas to help you
explode your company
you have to make time for it on a
consistent basis in your business the
number one rule if you want to make more
money
is you have to bring more value want to
make money quickly
provide value quickly want to make tons
of money
provide tons of value if you are not
making money yet it's because
people don't see the value that you
bring
and we're gonna change that in this
video so one of the first people that i
had any kind of arrangement with on the
top 10 series that i had on my channel
was tony robbins i made a video on tony
robbins i don't know how many years ago
now
the first top ten that did on him and
his team put it on his youtube channel
so it may still be there if you go to
his youtube channel
and then look at the playlist you'll see
that one of those videos is the video
that i made on him
so many years back and i started trying
to bring as much value to his team as
possible
tony's a really busy guy uh i'd loved
him from all the books
that he's written and the cd programs
that i listened to
i hadn't been to an event yet at that
point and i was just trying to bring
value to
tony's team i didn't know him personally
yet and
it frustrated me that he wasn't more on
youtube and i thought hey this guy needs
to be on more on youtube
i want more content for my channel and i
just think i think the world needs more
amazing speakers and thought leaders out
there creating content on youtube so
people can learn
and so i kept in touch with this team
and i said hey i'd love to help promote
tony i'd love to help you
with your youtube channel i'd love to
have tony on my channel
and and i just kept trying to find ways
to bring value to his team
consistently and following up and
finally here's what happened finally
they agreed hey yeah let's have tony
come and do an interview on your team
and finally they said hey let's have
tony come and do an interview on your
channel
and i was so excited i was super nervous
to have tony robbins on my channel it's
gonna be a big deal
and then like the day of or the day
before
he had to cancel for for something
happened something came up on his
schedule no problem he had to cancel
and all of the nerves and energy is like
oh no now it now led to disappointment
that
is finally gonna happen and then it's
not gonna happen then he said we'll try
to
we'll try to book it in as soon as
possible to get to get it happening
because
tony wants to be on your channel great
it took two years
before we actually got tony on the
channel afterwards two years
and and that's not that's not the throw
shade of tony i love him
he's busy he's doing his own thing i
wasn't bringing enough value to
to make it sooner uh but what i did was
i kept in touch i kept following up not
just saying hey is tony ready yet hey is
turning ready hey is tony ready it
no i'm bringing value i'm helping them
with their youtube channel i'm giving
them suggestions
i'm helping promote their events i was
doing stuff to try to still be in the
circle to stay top of mind
so that when the next opportunity came
up which happened to be when he launched
his next book
to say i want to be top of mind and tony
agreed to do
five different remote interviews uh for
the for his new book and i was one of
the five and and his team
said you've been so valuable to us
you've been helping us so much we
appreciate it
uh we want you to be one of the five
that tony does at an interview with like
it's happening
is that huff pinch me for real this time
i hope it's happening
and then the day out showed up and and
and i was super stressed out and nervous
about asking the right questions and
trying to bring value again i don't want
to disappoint people
and uh and it went he showed up it went
great we had an awesome interview
and at the end he then said hey evan uh
i'd like to invite you as my guest to my
next
uh seminar which is coming up in uh new
jersey unleash the power then
and he invited me to like front row
seats
special lounge access and all all the
perks
uh meet him backstage because he wanted
to chat and take a picture
which then led to more events and other
opportunities and then speaking and then
you know connecting with brandon
burchard's team and like lots of stuff
happened
through the tony robbins world and
connection
because i stayed and i followed up
because i kept trying to bring value and
even after the first time when
they got the cancellation on me i still
followed up for two more years and kept
providing value for two more years right
it's dog on the bone i want this to work
i'm gonna find another way through
until finally it did and then things
took off and so the same thing for you
and your business if you want to have
success
it's about thinking about ways you can
provide more value it's not that you
can't provide values not that you're not
talented and that you're not a genius
you are
people just don't recognize the value
that you can bring yet and you haven't
figured out how to bring that to market
in a way that you're going to get paid
to do it so my three-step process so
that you can provide more value
and get paid what you're worth let's go
step number one is build your top 50
list think about who are the 50 people
that if they knew you if they liked you
if they trusted you if they respected
you
if they recognized who you were and and
knew what you were up to
that that would mean something right for
a lot of people
it doesn't matter if they know you or
not they're not going to be a referral
source they're not going to be a partner
for you
but who are the 50 people that matter
most that that
you would love to have as dream clients
or dream partnerships
build that list of 50 people that you
want to make contact with
step number two is be their chief goal
officer if you want to have success and
this isn't just for the 50 list but
for your clients for your team for your
relationships
be the person's chief goal officer when
you understand
not just what you want but what they
want and you help them get it
that's when the whole world opens up the
reason why i was able to get
to to work with tony robbins and his
team was
i made a video at the starting point
right i made a video that they liked
that
that put tony in a good light uh that
was respectful that
made him look as well as a as a business
guru
on top of everything else that he was
already doing and then
every interaction i had afterwards i'm
bringing them value i'm helping them
with their youtube channel helping
spread the awareness for
programs and courses that he has coming
up right i'm trying to be a
a resource for them but around things
that they care about
not the things that i want to talk about
it's what they care about and so if
you're following your 50 people
right you have your list of 50 pay
attention to what they're talking about
try to catch them when they're in a time
of need right so classic examples are
when somebody's pitching a book
or when they're pitching a new deal or
where they're trying to get eyeballs on
a new show that they just launched like
what are they talking about
if they've gone super dark and super
quiet and they're not active on any of
their social platforms
it's really hard to start to make an
entrance
one of the people on my list has just
gone dark and we've had a good
relationship with the past
two years and now he's gone dark he's in
book writing mode
it's like i'm in book writing mode now
and i'm not gonna surface for the next
four months
so i'm not gonna send him anything in
the next four months he's not gonna be
posting anything for the next four
months
there's no point in me reaching out and
seeing how he's doing the next four
months because he doesn't want to be
bothered
but when he resurfaces and comes up for
air you know what he's going to need
he's going to need promotion he's going
gonna need marketing he's gonna need
support you know who's gonna be there
this guy right like that's the process
if you
promote my book right now it just came
out i'm just in launch mode i'm trying
to get eyeballs on it right
if you promote my book right now if i'm
on your list i'm way more likely to
reshare your stuff
to share the post to pay attention to
who you are
than in two months if you did the same
thing and that's for everybody
everybody's going in these cycles
what do they care about most right now
what matters most to them right now
and then you finding a way to be a
resource to help them so that they know
who you are they recognize your name and
say
that person that person's awesome i love
that person
when you get to that point then when you
reach out with an ask when you say hey
i'd love if you could xyz
they're way more receptive to you
because of all the value that you've
brought
be their chief goal officer understand
what they want and help them get it
and then you can ask for what you want
and set number three is then just
constantly follow up with value where
most people
quit is they don't get an immediate
response the more
successful the person is that you're
chasing down the harder it's going to be
to reach them
the harder it's going to be to penetrate
them right so you have to consistently
follow through
right like just look again at my tony
robbins example took it took a while to
get that first interview
that got cancelled they promised to do
another one it took two years before
that next one happened
of of constantly following up right not
not every day but a couple times a month
constantly
sending some value pitching ideas
helping them with their youtube channel
always through tony's team to the point
where it's like this guy evan is
bringing us so much value
once tony's opening up his calendar
again we have to make a spot for him
right most people quit too soon would
you wait
you know a year to get the first thing
and then two years before it actually
happens right another two years would
you wait that long would you follow up
that much like if you're on a a short
timeline and that this business
has to work in six months and you're
gonna sell it to do something else
this isn't the strategy but if you're on
a lifelong path like these are people
who you want to work with these are
these are your heroes who you can't wait
to get in front of
then you have to follow through you got
to stay on it be their chief gold
officer but don't give up
after the first time if you're not
getting results right
if you dm me and i don't respond the
first time if you leave an amazing
comment and i don't see it like that's
gonna happen
you're gonna get lost in the shuffle a
lot of times and especially if you're
only doing it once
but if every time i go live on instagram
you're there
asking great questions showing love and
support when i went live on youtube
talking about
my book if you were there right asking
questions showing love to the people
if you bought the book and shared it
with your story right
i'm gonna notice you and and forget
about me maybe
you know who cares about me great the
next person gary vee or tony robbins or
kevin hart or will smith
or oprah whoever the person is that you
love the most
right your top 50 you're constantly
paying attention and at any given point
in time
not all 50 of them are going to need
something but
inevitably somebody on that list right
now needs something
they need help they need support they
need outreach they need marketing
they need exposure you can help be that
person for them
and then they're going to remember you
the constant never-ending
ongoing outreach of value to build the
business that you want to build
most entrepreneurs don't charge enough
you're so worried about getting rejected
or losing clients because of a higher
price
that you'll charge just enough so you
stay just above
their survival line that's not how
winning businesses are built
if you can't break your survival
mentality you'll stay in survival mode
forever
so the first brand deal that i ever got
was for 500
from a major telecommunications company
and they wanted me to write for their
website
and they hired me they hired nine other
people to write an
article and they said write 300 words
we'll pay you 500 bucks
and for me 500 bucks at the time i
thought this is great
it's amazing i got my first deal 500
bucks is cash
i'm pumped but more important i'm
getting a link from
a huge company and for anybody back in
the old school seo days
if you get linked from a big company
that can mean a lot for your business to
take off for rankings
so i would have done it for free just
for the link so they gave me the 500
bucks
but i didn't just write the 300 words
because i wanted to
give more value i wanted to get paid
based off the value that i could provide
and so i had to show them
here's how much value i can bring and so
instead of writing 300 words
i wrote 1500 words right five times more
than what they asked
and then i made a video talking about it
and then i also promoted it to my
newsletter list
promoted to my audience let people know
when that article came up
here it was and so what happened as a
result of me doing all this work
i was the only one doing it so when they
came to the end of the series
i had my posts that were crushing it and
then nine other people were doing what
was asked the 300 words
the bare minimum what is asked of you is
the bare minimum
that's your ticket into the door if you
just did what they asked that's not
enough
that's not giving them insane value and
so i was the only one that they hired
10 of us went in i was the only one who
kept going because i brought them way
more value
now i started charging more what i was
doing i went from 500 bucks
per post to a thousand to 1500 to 2000
kept increasing my prices because i was
bringing them the value and they could
see it
and so the very beginning i was grateful
i was just grateful to get the gig i was
grateful to get my first
corporate gig to get 500 bucks to get a
link from the website i was grateful i
was pumped i was i was happy i was
excited this is the best
but i wanted to make this a business and
you can't have a business on 500 bucks a
month
and so i had to ask myself how do i
bring more value if i want to get paid
more
i need to bring more value and either
these guys are going to recognize it
or somebody else will i'm going to give
you a three-step process
you can use to start charging more step
number one is give the baker's dozen
i don't know how common a term this is
but i remember when i was young growing
up at my
at my cottage we'd always go to this
local bake shop and they sold donuts
and they would sell a 12 pack of donuts
but they would add a 13th one in for
free and they called it the baker's
dozen a dozen is supposed to be 12
but they give you a 13th donut for free
so you get your 12 and you can pick one
more
for free as a bonus as an extra as more
value
and so you want to think about that in
your business as well think about all
the clients that you're helping
how can you give the baker's dozen how
can you give that one extra donut that
one extra little bit of value
not of what you want to do but what is
actually valuable for them
right in the example of my client i
wrote five times as many words i added
the video
i promoted to my newsletter list think
about being your client's chief goal
officer
what are they trying to accomplish
they're hiring you for something but
they also have bigger goals in their
life or business
what are they trying to accomplish and
the more you can help them
accomplish that thing the more they're
going to love you the more they're going
to refer you and the more they're going
to pay you
for helping them out and so adopt the
baker's dozen mentality
you're just assuming that what is on
paper is not going to be enough
that that's just the entry point that's
the bare minimum you're always going to
add in that extra doughnut
step two increase your prices by 30
just try it for your next client
increase your prices 30
a big problem for a lot of entrepreneurs
is you're already doing the baker's
dozen you're doing more than the baker's
dozen you're given insane value you're
spending an incredible amount of time
researching helping thinking about your
client and you're just not getting paid
enough for it
and so your next client that comes in
just try
30 more 30 more 30 percent more
and you'll slowly transition to people
that have bigger clients
because only doing work with people who
can't afford to pay you what you're
worth
is not how you're going to build a great
business it's honestly better to work
with people who can afford to pay you
and then you keep 10 of your clients to
be charity cases
that's actually even for free you don't
charge them it's free
it's your it's your community service
it's your work to give back
to the the community around you amazing
but you can't build your business off of
that
most of your business has to be of
people who are paying you what you're
worth
and so the next client that comes in you
summon your courage
you look at your typical price that you
would charge now it's 30
more and step three is start small i
love starting small
i hate having to go into a business and
do this giant pitch because it's a six
figure deal
i hate that it takes too long it has to
go through too many
pains has to have too many meetings it's
a committee to make a decision
just takes too long the best place to
start is small
just find the smallest deal to get
started on one tiny little thing that
you can do for them
and then be the best supplier that
they've ever worked with
be the best supplier that they have ever
worked with and guess what's gonna
happen
they're gonna fight for ways to bring
you back in when i did that deal with
the telecommunications company
they loved me so much they fought for
ways to have me come back in they
they wanted me to speak at events they
wanted me to interview people for their
channel
they were looking for ways like can we
give this to evan can we have evan do
this
sort of as one throw away thing one 300
word article
became a three-year relationship
something like that it's crazy
i want that for you i don't want you to
have to go through crazy big proposals
it takes six months to get a decision
find one tiny little thing that you can
get started off
and then show the value that you bring
and then they're gonna fight over
themselves to have you do more work
they'll say can you do this
can you do that we have a problem here
can you help out here too and if it's in
your wheelhouse and you say yes
i'm happy to help and suddenly you get
more and more and more of the entire
business
without ever having to pitch without
ever having to present
because you're bringing so much value i
think most people are confused about
money
most people don't have a healthy
relationship with money
there are the people who think that
money is everything the money is the
only important thing in the world and
you need to chase it down and it's your
duty and responsibility and obligations
like it's number one
the person walking into my house and my
place of business that's my next suit
that's my next payment that's my next
whatever it's only focused on money
and there's other people who think money
is the root of all
evil and that money is a bad thing
money is a tool money helps you get a
lot of things done money helps you go
places money helps you accomplish your
mission
money needs to be in your top five it's
just not number one
money needs to be in your top five if
money does not become important at some
point to you if it's not in your top
five priorities you'll never make money
and you'll always be
by yourself struggling trying to figure
out how to make something work
but it's not number one either if you
put money above all else you'll end up
doing a lot of work that you hate and
you never get good at it just because
you're chasing opportunities
this is a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs fail
you're just chasing the hottest thing
for this year
that you don't have a passion or
interest in and then you lose because
the people who love that destroy you
when i first started doing this helping
entrepreneurs i never thought i was
going to make money
my first speaking gig my first option to
help people was in canada in my hometown
of toronto was at a ymca it was a free
event
they had an entrepreneurship program and
they asked me to come and speak to their
members
it was free i wasn't getting paid to do
it just wanted to help out i just sold
my business i wanted to give back
i was saying yes to everything i
actually didn't even know what i wanted
to do next
and so i show up and this is big room
full of chairs
and only three people show up to that
first event
only three people and as soon as i
walked in the room and i saw three
people my heart sank
i felt like i'm never gonna be able to
make anything from this if only three
people show up to a free event
how am i ever going to make money from
it i didn't know
but i gave my best to those three people
i know that i helped those three people
and had an impact on their lives
we then went for coffee afterwards and
continued the conversation i know
that i helped them and it filled my soul
and had to find a way to keep doing it
i knew i had to find a way to keep doing
it even if i never made money
and so i did i kept doing speaking gigs
i did my website
i did my youtube channel and slowly
slowly slowly slowly
it started to come in as i figured out
the second key
important piece which is figuring out
how to bring value to other people
when you find something that you love
doing and you combine it with how it
brings value to other people
that's when you start making money
if it's something that you just love
doing but nobody else likes it
there's zero value to anybody else you
have a hobby
you have a hobby if you're only chasing
stuff that people like and need
but you don't like doing it you're never
gonna get great at it
you might make a little bit of money but
you're never gonna get great at it
you're never gonna be
all time you're never gonna build a huge
business
and so is that combination of doing work
that you love doing
and mix it with where does an
opportunity that people need
it's a problem that you are solving mix
those things together
you have a super successful business if
you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there